>> Jordan: MY OPPONENT TONIGHT
IS REPORTER FOR THE BAILEY BEAST
WILL SOMMER, DAILY BEAST, MEET
NIGHTLY BEAUTY.
, WILL, YOU WRITE A WEEKLY NEWS
LETTER ON THE CONSERVATIVE MEDIA
AND THE PROTRUMP INTERNET.
TELL ME, HOW DANK ARE THOSE
MEMES.
>> ARE YOU ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
THERE ARE A LOT OF MEMES.
THEY STARTED WITH PEPPY THE FROG
THERE ARE ALL KIENSD OF FROGS
NOW, THEY ARE VERY PRODUCTIVE.
>> IT GETS REALLY DANK OUT
THERE.
>> EXACTLY.
WHAT ARE YOU TRAFFICKING IN,
WHAT ARE YOU CHRONICLING IN.
>> EVERYTHING FROM THE AT RIGHT
TO KIND OF FRINGE INTERNET
TWITTER PERSONALITIES TO FOX
NEWS AND TALK RADIO. REALLY THE
WHOLE GAMUT OF THE RIGHT WING
MEDIA.
>> THAT IS-- THAT IS WHAT YOU
WOULD CONSIDER CONSERVATIVE
MEDIA.
>> HOW HAS THAT SHIFTED UNDER
DONALD TRUMP.
>> IT HAS GOTTEN CRAZIER.
>> YEAH, REALLY, I THINK TRUMP
LAS UPENDED A LOT OF WHAT WAS
THOUGHT OF AS THE TRADITIONAL
CONSERVATIVE MEDIA AND FORCED
PEOPLE LIKE FOX TO KIND OF GO
EVEN FURTHER RIGHT WHILE IT'S
ALSO EMPOWERED A LOT OF CRAZIER
ELEMENTS LIKE ALEX JONES.
>> INFOWARS HAS FOUND SOME
SUCCESS.
PLACES LIKE BREITBART FEELS LIKE
IT IS BECOMING SOMETHING
DIFFERENT WITH STEVE BANNON.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WHEN STEVE BANNON WAS IN CHARGE
BREITBART WAS AT THE FOREFRONT
OF THE TRUMP MOVEMENT.
AND NOW IT'S BEEN GONE, THE
WHOLE THING IS VERY TUMULTUOUS
RIGHT NOW.
>> I KNOW DONALD TRUMP IS IN
POWER.
HE'S THE MAN.
WE'RE LUCKY FOR THAT.
BUT THIS IS BUBBLING UP BEFORE
DONALD TRUMP.
IT WAS GIVEN SOME-- IF DONALD
TRUMP, I HATE TO SAY, THIS
HADN'T WON THE ELECTION, LET'S
SAY SOMETHING CRAZY WOULD HAPPEN
LIKE HE DIDN'T WIN THE POPULAR
VOTE, AND HILL RAE CLINTON WAS
IN OFFICE.
DO YOU THINK THIS WOULD STILL
EXIST.
HOW WOULD THAT LANDSCAPE LOOK
NOW.
>> AS HARD AS IT MAY BE TO
BELIEVE, IT WOULD PROBABLY BE
EVEN CRAZIER BECAUSE I MEAN
IMAGINE BENGHAZI TIMES A HUNDRED
IN TERMS OF ALL THE
INVESTIGATIONS, ALL THE
DIFFERENT KIND OF CONSPIRACY
THER REAL ESTATES, ALREADY
REPUBLICANS ARE IN POWER AND WE
KNOW HOW SEAN HANNITY GOES ON
FOX NEWS WITH A NEW CRAZY IDEA.
>> WHAT I AM CURIOUS B WHAT DO
YOU THINK THE YEFER ALL
CONNECTOR OF A LOT OF THIS RIGHT
WING MEDIA IS.
IS TRUMP THE ONE CONNECTOR
THERE, WHAT ARE THEY ALL
RALLYING BEHIND.
>> I WOULD SAY IT IS TRUMP RIGHT
NOW.
I MEAN THE POLICIES ARE
CONSTANTLY SHIFTING.
EVEN DAY TO DAY BASED ON WHAT
TRUMP AND THE ADMINISTRATION ARE
DOING.
SO IN THE PAST MAYBE 10, 20
YEARS AGO WE WOULD BE USED TO
MUCH MORE POLICY ORIENTED IDEAS
COMING FROM CONSERVATIVES.
NOW IT IS MORE OF AN ATTITUDE IN
THE RIGHT WING MED YARKS IN
TERMS OF LET'S TRIGGER SOME
LIBS, THAT KIND OF STUFF.
>> Jordan: ONE OF MY FAVORITE
GAMES.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE ULTIMATE
GOAL IS FOR THE MORE
CONSERVATIVE OUTLETS, TO FIND
THE TRUTH, EXPOSE THE TRUTH?
>> WHY ARE YOU LAUGHING?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK OBVIOUSLY
LIKE ANY MEDIA ORGANIZATION,
THEY'RE BUSINESSES AND AT THE
SAME TIME YOU WANT TO BE
CONSTRUCTING A WORLD WHERE
THINGS ARE ALWAYS, YOU KNOW,
WITH PARTISANSHIP ON THE STRIES
KIND OF LIKE ROOTING FOR A
FOOTBALL TEAM AND YOU WANT TO
CHECK OUT WHAT THE NEWS THAT
GOOD FOR YOUR TEAM.
IN THIS CASE WHEN TRUMP HAS A
LOT OF BAD NEWS, THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL CONSERVATIVE OUTLETS
AND PERSONALITIES OFFER AN
ALTERNATIVE WHEREAS LIKE
ACTUALLY TRUMP IS CONSTANTLY
WINNING.
>> THAT I AGREE WITH.
>> BUT I DONE THINK THESE THINGS
ARE ACTING LIKE BUSINESSES.
THEY'RE ACTING LIKE TRUTH TERLS
F THAT GETS YOU UPSET GO TO SHOP
POSITION.COM AND GET ONE OF OUR
MUSCLE RELAXERS AND CHILL OUT.
TALK TO ME ABOUT HOW INFORMATION
TRAVELS ON THE RIGHT.
I KNOW FROM FOX NEWS' EARS OR
MOUTH TO DONALD TRUMP'S EARS.
HOW DOES IT GET TO FOX NEWS.
>> SURE, SO THERE IS A KIND OF
FASCINATING ECOSYSTEM ON THE
RIGHT WHERE THESE IDEAS
ESPECIALLY CONSPIRACY THEORIES
BUB EP YOU WILL,.
>> Jordan: TRUE-SPIR ANSI.
>> I DON'T MEENT TO OFFEND.
>> Jordan: YOU DON'T HAVE TO
LAUGH, THEY ARE TRUTH-SERIES.
>> OFTEN IT WILL BE WHETHER IT
IS PEOPLE ON TWITTER, REDDIT OR
THESE INCREASINGLY YOUTUBE AND
SO THESE IDEAS KIND OF PERCOLATE
AND AT THAT LEVEL THERE IS JUST
TONS OF CRAZY IDEAS.
AND THEN MAYBE THEY LAND ON A
SITE LIKE THE GATEWAY PUNDIT OR
BREITBART OR INFOWARS AND
EVENTUALLY ON FOX NEWS OR RUSH
LIMBAUGH.
>> WHAT ARE SOME OF THE IDEAS
NOW.
>> WELL, SO, THE BIG ONE THAT IS
GETTING PUSHED RIGHT NOW IS THE
IDEA OF IMPEACHING OBAMA.
>> I LOVE IT.
>> AND SO YOU SAY OBAMA IS NO
LONGER THE PRESIDENT, RIGHT.
>> Jordan: THANK GOD.
>> BUT.
>> Jordan: STILL, LET'S GET
HIM OUT THERE OF.
>> SO SOME PEOPLE CAME UP WITH
THE IDEA AND THEY ARE CONSTANTLY
A COUNTERNARRATIVE TO THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION AND PEOPLE
WANT ON THE RIGHT THEY WANT TO
GET SOMEONE ON THE LEFT RIGHT
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS NOT
REALLY A REAL PROMINENT FIGURE
ON THE LEFT IN THE SAME WAY
TRUMP SON THE RIGHT.
SO THE IDEA BEING THAT IF YOU
ARE IMPEACHED THEN ARE YOU NO
LONGER PRESIDENT, YOU STILL
CAN'T HOLD FEDERAL OFFICE IN THE
FUTURE SO IF OBAMA WANTED TO BE
A SENATOR OR SOMETHING, IT WOULD
BE KIND OF LIKE A THUMB IN HIS
EYEWITNESSES YEAH, GREAT.
>> IS FINDING AN ENEMY A TENET
OF CONSERVATIVE MEDIA.
>> I WOULD SAY SO THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL ONES ARE THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL IDEAS AND OUTLETS ARE
CONSTANTLY COMING UP WITH
ENEMIES THAT CAN BE ATTACKED AND
DIRT ON THOSE ENEMIES.
AS WE SAW IN THE 25016 CAMPAIGN
SO MANY IDEAS CAME OUT ABOUT
HILLARY CLINTON.
THE LATEST IS SHE HAS THE LUMP
UNDER THE JACKET AND THEY SAID
SHE IS WEARING LIKE A BODY, LIKE
A ROBOT SUIT UNDERNEATH.
>> YEAH, EXACTLY.
>> Jordan: I THINK THAT IS
PRETTY BASIC.
>> YEAH.
>> BECAUSE SHE IS HALF CYBORG
HALF AN HE FEM KNIT NAZI I
THINK, WE ARE STILL HAMMERING
THE DETAILS BUT I CAN'T WAIT FOR
THE OFFICIAL UNVEIL WHEN TRUMP
TWEETS ABOUT IT IN A WEEK AND A
HALF.
TELL ME SOMETHING I ALREADY
KNOW.
>> WELL, REALLY I WOULD SAY
CONSERVATIVE MEDIA HAS NEVER
BEEN MORE IMPORTANT TO THE
POLITICS OF THE COUNTRY.
THESE IDEAS GO FROM FOX AND
FRIENDS SAY OR INFOWARS RIGHT TO
BEING TWEETED BY THE PRESIDENT.
SO EVEN IF IT ISN'T POLITICALLY
WHAT YOU ARE INTERESTED IN, I
THINK IT IS PRETTY IMPORTANT TO
KEEP UP WITH.
>> Jordan: BUSINESS BE
BOOMING.
REPORTER FOR THE DAILY BEAST